Speaker 1: Over the weekend, we started to
see not only the protests as a result of the
full not guilty verdicts for Kyle
Rittenhouse in Kenosha, Wisconsin.
We also started to see covered protests turned
violent around the world. Now you might say,
David, why are people protesting the
virus? No, no, no. What I mean is
protests around COVID guidelines. Many countries
starting to put in place stricter guidelines for
the unvaccinated as cases are spiking dramatically
in many countries in Europe, including
Germany, Austria and others. And the protests
against guidelines against vaccine requirements
are turning increasingly violent, violent.
I'm going to give you a little bit of a tour
through some of these Dutch police. Police arrest
seven amid unrest in The Hague. Police arrested
seven rioters in The Hague after youths set fire
in the streets and threw fireworks at officers.
The unrest came a day after police
opened fire on protesters in Rotterdam
amidst violence that broke out at a
protest against coronavirus restrictions.
That's in The Hague. The rioting in The Hague was
on a smaller scale than the pitched battles on the
streets of Rotterdam, where police say three
rioters were hit by bullets and investigations
are underway to figure out if they were shot by
police in Austria, Italy and Croatia. Protests
erupt over virus rules. Tens of thousands
of protesters, many from far right groups,
marched through Vienna, Austria, on Saturday
after this nationwide lockdown was announced.
Austrian lockdown starts today comes as
average daily deaths have tripled. Hospitals
in heavily hit states are reaching capacity.
Lockdown will be at least 10 days could be 20.
This continuing in so many different parts of the
world. In Italy, 3000 turned out in the capital
Circus Maximus, where ancient time in ancient
times Romans would have popular entertainment
to protest the green pass certificates required to
go to workplaces, restaurants, cinemas, theaters,
sports venues and gyms, and long distance train,
bus and ferry travel in Northern Ireland. People
opposed to vaccine passports protest protested
outside the City Hall in Belfast. Some protesters
carried signs that have been widely criticized
as offensive, comparing coronavirus restrictions
to the actions of Nazi Germany in Croatia.
Thousands have gathered in France. There have been
violent protesters. I'm sorry. In France, they
have been condemning violent protester protests
in the Caribbean island of Guadeloupe, one of
France's overseas territories where cars have
been set on fire. Tens of thousands protest
Belgium's tighter COVID 19 rules, you see
police fire hoses brought out to try to quell
protests. Tens of thousands demonstrating their.
Marchers. Marchers came to protest the
government's strong advice to get vaccinated
and any possible moves to impose mandatory shots.
Shouting Freedom, Freedom, Freedom and singing the
anti-fascist song Bella Chow. Protesters lined up
behind a banner that says together for freedom.
Dutch police arrest more than 30 amid ongoing
unrest already looked at one article of that
they are describing an orgy of violence.
Interesting language. And France has sent special
forces to the Caribbean region of Guadeloupe,
overcovered riots. What is the end game here?
Because it is increasingly looking like
there are going to be ebbs and flows of COVID
for at least a couple more years? Now
there is the hope based on Israeli data,
that the third dose creates more lasting immunity
than the initial set or regimen of two doses.
And of course, if that's the case, if people get
vaccinated, we may see a more permanent decline in
COVID rates and particularly hospitalizations and
deaths. But at this point, it's pretty clear based
on the level of interest in getting vaccinated and
a variety of countries, which is too low, that at
least for a couple of years, while we hopefully
wait as Vincent Racaniello told us, may happen for
a decline in the severity of COVID as we wait for
that, that there is going to be a very long period
of time of the ebbs and flows. So what do we do?
Do we learn to sort of live with it? Do we say,
Well, you've got to just continue with a sort of
semi restricted way of life for a couple of years?
Do you go to let it rip at a certain point, as
many have suggested saying, well, one, once the
vaccines are widely available for everyone, it
becomes personal responsibility. There's problems
with that. I don't have the answer. But what's in
increasingly clear is no one. To the extent that
there are guidelines, there are going to be people
protesting and hopefully not, but worryingly
an increasingly violent fashion number one and
number two, this is not going away anytime soon.
And so I don't know the answer. We're going to
be doing an interview next week. I think it is
related to the kind of bigger picture at this
point in time, but I'm curious to hear from you.
What should happen, given that this is likely
to be the case for years, and I know people who
are saying, I don't know that I'm ever going
to a restaurant again. OK, that's certainly
one approach. But self-selecting out of life has
its own problems not to quote Donald Trump, but
over the long term. Obviously, that's going to
create a problem as well. What should be done
at this point? Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman
and we'll have a continuing conversation about
this. So we are going to be doing another one
of our great viewer town halls, this next one has
been scheduled for December 14th. We're going to
do it at 6:00 p.m. Eastern Time. It will be
streaming live on the second YouTube channel,
the Pacman Live YouTube channel, which
you can find at YouTube.com slash
Pacman Live. I think we took something
like 60 or 70 different calls from
viewers on the last one. And of course,
members will get priority during the town
hall. You can sign up at Join Pacman
Dot Com. I encourage you to do so.